wissen dass heute das präsidium der cdu
getagt hat und auch der bundesvorstand
in einer sehr schwierigen situation und
aber dass die regierungskrise oder die
koalitionskrise wir wollen wenn man das
bezeichnen will
aufgeschoben ist aber nicht aufgehoben
also das ist keine einigung was da heute
passiert ist und man überbrückt die zeit
dadurch dass man eben sagt man dass
durch das darf es auf europäischer ebene
noch mal beraten werden
es gibt dinge die dringend geändert
werden müssen
wir haben diese ganze thematik
immigration noch nicht wirklich im griff
in der ganzen auseinandersetzung mit der
csu ist die merkel ist die kanzlerin
nicht unbedingt gestärkt wurden ja das
ist schon klar aber auch die csu muss
natürlich am anfang dieser woche war das
ganze nicht gerade ein erfolg der csu
weil seehofer hat man seit wochen
angekündigt er werde diesen masterplan
vorlegen und einen tag vorher muss er
das absagen das war für die csu auch
nicht schön also eigentlich haben sich
erstmal beide geschwächt würde ich sagen
und rauskommen aus dieser ganzen affäre
wird man wahrscheinlich nur wenn wenn
beide stück weit nachgegeben werden also
auch merkel wird nach geben müssen wenn
sie das nicht tut dann würde ich sagen
dann ist die koalition vorbei und ich
habe auch mit horst seehofer darüber
gesprochen was die zusammenarbeit
anbelangt eine bundeskanzlerin und ein
bundesinnenminister müssen
gesprächsfähig seien die sicherheitslage
in deutschland ist nicht einfach
und deshalb ist das voraussetzung und
diese voraussetzung ist gegeben wenn es
jetzt auf europäischer ebene nun
überhaupt nicht funktioniert gut dann
geht man im streit auseinander und ich
glaube dann dann hat frau merkel hier zu
hause ganz ganz schlechte karten
aber wie das auf europäischer ebene so
ist es wird wahrscheinlich irgendein
ergebnis sei mit dem alle irgendwie
leben können
und mit eben auch frau merkel hier
wahrscheinlich den eindruck erwecken
kann
dass das ähnliche wirkung hat wie das
was die csu haben will man hat sich ja
jetzt auch die formel geeinigt der eu
gipfel muss maßnahmen beschließen die
wirkungsgleich zudem sind was die csu
haben wir wirkungsgleich ist ein sehr
schwammiger begriff ja also zurzeit muss
man ja sowieso sagen dass die zahlen auf
relativ niedrigem niveau sind über die
wir sprechen und davon wirkungsgleich
dann zu sprechen das ist eine petition
sa wir als csu unterstützen auf diesem
feld jede europäische lösung jedes
bemühen und europäische lösungen
da haben wir nie einen zweifel daran
gelassen wir sind für viele politische
entscheidungen die europa gestaltet
haben nicht verantwortlich